Nikki Glaser you have it all the name of
a professional porn star and the body of
an amateur porn star you know I'm a big
supporter of the meetcha movement but
remember Nikki me too shouldn't just be
what a guy says to his friend when he
tells him he had sex with Nikki Glaser
oh there are so many celebrities here
tonight we have men from movies women
from TV and lil rel from I'm guessing
the California Raisins oh and now the
lovely Cybill Shepherd is here I
remember years ago when I heard there
was going to be a movie a TV movie about
me I thought oh god no because they're
always so dreadful I was really nervous
well you can imagine my relief when I
found out civil Shepard was going to
play me
I thought civil Shepard great no one
will see it
now civil isn't it interesting that your
career basically ended after that role
as if you defended someone someone with
power
someone with vast resources and money
who could cook up such a plan who could
craft such a scheme it was me bitch
[Applause]
[Music]
you